encuentra la distancia entre el punto
menos dos menos cuatro este punto de
aquí y la línea de igual a menos un
tercio de x más dos que es esta línea de
aquí
ahora para hacerlo solo tenemos que
encontrar la línea perpendicular a esta
línea azul allí es igual a menos un
tercio de x más 2 que contenga este
punto de aquí que contenga este punto
entonces tenemos que obtener tenemos que
obtener la ecuación de esta línea y
luego debemos de encontrar donde se
intersectan estas dos líneas y luego
tenemos que encontrar la distancia entre
estos dos puntos de intersección y
entonces tenemos la distancia más corta
entre este punto y esta línea de aquí el
primer paso es determinar cuál es la
pendiente de esta línea perpendicular la
pendiente de la línea perpendicular va a
ser el inverso negativo de la pendiente
de esta línea azul
por lo que el inverso negativo de un
tercio negativo va a ser 3 positivo
entonces esta línea de aquí va a tener
una pendiente de 3 va a tener la forma
de g
igual
x más de donde ves la ordenada al origen
y a simple vista se puede ver aquí
que estará muy cerca de 2 pero
verifiquemos eso
para saber el valor de b sustituyamos
este punto de aquí sabemos no solo que
la pendiente de esta recta es 3 sino
también que este punto debe de
pertenecer a ella por lo que este punto
debe de satisfacer esta ecuación
entonces cuando x es menos 210 menos 4
entonces tenemos
- 4
es igual
- 2
y déjame escribir el -2 ahí adentro
es por dos negativos más b
y ahora podemos resolver para p
tenemos que menos 4 es igual
menos 6 más
y si sumamos seis de los dos lados
tenemos que 2
es igual
ave
v
es igual a 2 entonces vamos a escribir
que la ordenada al origen para la
segunda línea exentos inmediatamente
podemos ver o podemos verificar donde se
intersectan ambas intersectan al eje y
angy igual a 2 para las 2 cuando x es
igual a 0 y es igual a todos
si no fuera tan obvio podríamos igualar
estas dos ecuaciones podríamos decir
mire tenemos
x + 2 ahora sabemos que esto es 3 x + 2
porque es 2 y cuando está 3 x + 2 es
igual
a menos
versión de x + 2
bueno veamos si restamos 2 en ambos
lados cuando 3x es igual a menos un
tercio de x hay un par de cosas que
podríamos hacer en este momento
podríamos sumar un tercio de x en ambos
lados y luego tendríamos
tendríamos tres más un tercio que es lo
mismo que 10
tercios de x igual a 0 y si multiplicas
ambos lados por 3 decimos
decimos obtienes obtienes x es igual a
cero entonces ambas líneas se
intersectan cuando x es igual a 0 para
las 2 cuando x es igual a 0 y es igual a
2 cuando x es igual a cero es igual a 2
pero lo pudiste haber visto aquí a
simple vista podrías haber visto que las
ordenadas al origen de las dos que si x
es igual a 0 y es igual a 2 este punto
es
como dos y ya sabíamos que este punto de
aquí era menos dos coma menos cuatro y
ahora sólo necesitamos encontrar la
distancia entre estos dos puntos y la
fórmula de la distancia es en realidad
sólo una aplicación del teorema de
pitágoras solo necesitas encontrar la
distancia el cambio en la dirección de
iu y el cambio en la dirección en x así
que hagamos eso por separado
entonces en la dirección
en la dirección ya que es esta distancia
de aquí
desde iu igual a menos 4 hasta 2 esta
distancia de aquí es 6 y cuál es esta
distancia de aquí vamos de x igual a
menos 2 a x igual a 0 por lo que esta
distancia de aquí es 2 por lo que la
distancia entre estos dos puntos es sólo
la hipotenusa de un triángulo recto
cuyos catetos son 6 y 2
así que podemos decir si le llamamos a
esta distancia d podríamos decir que la
distancia al cuadrado es igual a
y lo único que estoy haciendo aquí es
reafirmando la fórmula de la distancia
la fórmula de la distancia te dice todo
esto ya sabes quietos era 72 menos que
uno que 6 al cuadrado pero eso es sólo
el teorema de pitágoras sólo digamos 6
al cuadrado
x 2 - x 1 que es 0 - 2 negativo lo que
es 2 positivos al cuadrado
va a ser igual a la distancia al
cuadrado pero vemos que es solo el
teorema de pitágoras de todas maneras
resolvamos para la distancia
así que la
distancia al cuadrado va a ser igual a
36 4 que es 40 y ahora veamos 40 es la
distancia al cuadrado puedo sólo decir
que la distancia es igual
la raíz cuadrada
la raíz cuadrada de 40 es lo mismo que
la raíz cuadrada de 4 por 10 entonces la
distancia es igual a 2 si factor izamos
el 4 la raíz cuadrada de 4 por raíz
cuadrada de 10 2 es la raíz de 42 por la
raíz cuadrada de 10 y hemos terminado